well physically I could but emotionally
and spiritually I can't can eat at the
same place
let's try someplace near there well your
idea of someplace news scares me a
little bit you guys so during lunch yeah
you know we were just thinking about it
you want in or yes I'm starving
just order me something from wherever
you guys are going you know me I'm super
low-maintenance so I'm high maintenance
because I like things done a certain way
absolutely um my name is Bennett I ain't
even in it okay I don't even know you do
my name is Paul that's between y'all so
you're saying this is low maintenance
well this is what I should aspire to
this is a far more nuanced conversation
than we should be but not too nuanced
right too nuanced and I might be labeled
as high maintenance
look do you want to order lunch with us
or not yes and from where should be
order this super low maintenance lunch
wherever wherever my name is Guinevere
and I'd gladly choose anywhere you
choose fine okay about here the menu
smells weird you know what I'm not
hungry
no okay does smell super weird
I'm into it fine you know I can't give
away my father's inheritance as I hear
his beard for three months okay
you